you got like 100 million people who ate
biden every trump voter
and half of the democrats it's just that
those half
hate trump more but once biden is the
target
then they're gonna be okay now that we
voted for you because we didn't like
trump we really don't like you two
i i still can't get past the fact that
biden supposedly got more votes than
obama when
half of the democrats hate him well this
is the thing everyone we had on
everyone we had on the show was biting
their tongue and saying
yeah i i voted for biden yeah
it's horrible well not everybody two
people well
that's everyone that i've been around
when i was co-hosting for me but
everyone i talked to has the same
sentiment
you know they were kind they were
bamboozled they were fooled to believe
maybe something but they knew deep down
that something was wrong and i think
most of america knows that so we're
going to see that play out
in our social discourse very soon we
already have black lives matter tweeting
at the biden administration like
hey we were supposed to meet hey guys
what's going on here a cop
yeah the top prosecutor that sent
innocent people away to jail knowingly
knowingly she knew she knew people were
innocent she still made them rot in jail
and ruined
their lives i mean that is it kind of
brings me a weird
sense of joy because i'm demented that
black lives matter helped get
like i just love it paradoxical man
that's the craziest thing it's like you
know what a lot of people we've had on
and uh we're not even who we've had on
but like people who have come here and
we've talked
when they say they vote for biden i'm
like oh yeah why well you know trump's
bad before what what do you do
come on come on come on man you can't
you can't
like i can sit here and i can go through
everything trump's done in his family
and we can talk about the monuments
clause and his resorts and his
businesses
you can talk about shady business deals
and all that stuff it doesn't compare
to joe biden now if we're gonna have
like you know a turd sandwich versus a
giant douche i understand why people
might be like i don't know man i voted
for biden
but if you're if so these are low
information people
a lot of these people are young like we
had to do it on the other day he's 24.
he doesn't know anything about the joe
biden administration he was like a
teenager not paying attention to when
joe biden and obama were in
and the horrible things they were doing
so it's like you know you know the left
was protesting
obama right with with you know black
lives matter started under obama occupy
wall street was under obama
he wasn't like this great left-wing
leader that they're telling you now and
joe biden was a part of that
it's it's like you're complaining about
systemic racism joe biden's the guy
who's been in office for 47 years who
made that stuff
and and helped facilitate these wars you
don't got a good reason for voting for
the guy i'm sorry
i understand if you came to me and said
i didn't vote for anybody i bet yeah i
get it but saying you voted for biden
nah there's no excuse
you just didn't know what you were
talking about but then but you know
so if he got 80 million votes i think
people just were told by the media you
know orange man bad they believed it
well this dominion stuff
could there might be merit to that
dominion stuff well that
report that came out you saw that
cassandra the antrim report
that said that votes were intended like
those the machines intentional had
intentional errors
so you can't ex you can't just tr
you know the the traditional culture
where arguments don't work on this or
they're like oh the guy's biased
the guy the guy who wrote it's bias i'm
like i don't know anything about that no
i'm sorry
i just write a report i don't know who
that guy is well he's biased i don't
care
investigate the evidence tell me what
happened
i don't care about your opinions on
politics it's not going to solve
anything
and that's all they have so far i'm not
not like anything's going to happen from
them i'm thinking about the inception of
occupy
and that was basically when obama bailed
out
um freddie mac and fannie mae
um the big banker bailout 2008 yeah
trillions of dollars inflated i don't
know how much he inflated the currency
but
well there was the national public
bailouts and then there was the secret
federal reserve bailouts that i talked
about with ben bernanke and he got angry
and tried to rip away my microphone
i brought that up i was like what about
the secret trillion
dollars that you gave out that no one
knows and then he got mad and livid and
literally had me kicked out and they
just did it again with a three trillion
that they printed
in like yeah well right now blackrock is
being financed by the federal reserve
all of their losses are being subsidized
by the federal reserve just printing
money and giving it to them right now
as the average taxpayer stands by and
says
you got anything for me and then the big
banksters are like printer go burn no
more for you
yeah printer broke yeah there's yeah the
meme is a bunch of pigs with
with top hats and the guy's cranking the
money printer and the money's flying out
and he's like screaming and his eyes are
bleeding or whatever and then the
capitalist pig is like it's literally a
picture of a pig with like a cop hat and
a monocle is like smiling and taking the
money
and then below it it's uh one of those
like really sad looking you know
guys and he's all he's like please need
i need money for food and then there's
an angry person holding the thing saying
the printer broke
yes there's no money for you but there's
money for all the big business
so money went burr and 08 was it when
they tremendously
so and then two years later occupy
struck so now we're looking at the
printing now maybe in a year or a year
and a half we're going to see another
occupy
but we're already kind of seeing it with
these autonomous zones they just haven't
been forced into it like people haven't
lost their houses
well they're starting to people are
losing their houses
like crazy evictions are coming soon
occupy didn't have focus
it lacked the they a lot of people were
down on the federal reserve
yeah it got it got like muddled a bunch
of weird like social justice people came
in
and took over and then made it literally
about nothing but it should have been
about the federal reserve and taking
back the money supply i think it was
it was about wall street it was about
occupying wall street literally the plan
was to go
down to like wall and broad in new york
and sit there making demands
it kind of doesn't make sense because
people don't know what wall street is
there was i remember we were down there
and a bunch of the activists got into
you know in front of walmart
they they barricaded it basically but
people eventually found their way in
and some guy came out and he was like
what are you even protesting
and they're like wall street he's like
what retirement funds
what are you talking about i started
laughing that was hilarious yeah because
wall street's a lot of retirement funds
like 401ks and iras and stuff
people think it's just like wall street
just repre like is is a phrase to
represent powerful corporate interest it
doesn't necessarily mean that's what
wall street literally is doing
but that's what the original focus was
that the big banks
got these big bailouts and regular
people didn't
and so that was the issue instead
you know the older people the
libertarian types a lot of the ron paul
types who were there
left because guess what they have jobs
and then the young people who didn't
have jobs were sleeping in the park
and then the kids who had apartments in
brooklyn and their parents paid for a
couple trust fund kids i know they're
literally trust fund kids not all of
them but there were some they had no
jobs so they were like
this is my job now i'm gonna come here
and organize and that was it occupy wall
street became some weird social justice
progressive nonsense that made it made
no sense
they fought for nothing they were there
to bust up fractional reserve banking
and the federal reserve's fiat
that was not a statement from anything i
know unfortunately it just became about
like social justice but that was that
was never a stated goal of occupy wall
street
but those conversations did happen
but the the original call for occupy was
was for
uh was for the far left who organized
one month before
to organize what it was going to be what
was going to look like and they wanted
to occupy
wall street and it was for far left
causes
there was no official planning
organization where they were like the
federal reserve and fractional banking
or whatever those conversations happened
especially with the ron paul people
so basically what we need to do is tell
everybody that radiohead's going to
perform at the federal reserve
that's what they did people don't know
yeah dude i was i was i was there when
it happened and i remember when
they they announced radio was coming i
was like that's not true yeah yeah and
thousands of people showed up
and then the guy's like okay before they
he he's like
we're gonna let you know right hood's
not really playing here but now that
you're here we're gonna do a general
assembly
it was actually quite brilliant yeah
because there's two things
first the people who were there i talked
to this young woman i was like so did
you come here
for radiohead and she goes oh well i
came um for occupy
and i was like but to like watch
radiohead and she goes yeah
and i was like but they're not coming
she's like no but you know i'm i'm here
for the cause you know like not wanting
to be
you know admitting it so what they got
was
they did a general assembly where they
got everyone to mindless
mindlessly chant along to what they were
saying so one of the one of the things
they do at occupies is the people's mic
the far left does this all the time with
their protests where at a rally someone
will say
mic check and then everyone yells mic
check and then they'll say they'll start
saying something
and everyone repeats it that actually
creates uniformity between people
because they're getting people to chant
and say these things over and over again
so they have thousands of people show up
and they say mic check
and then everyone yells and they go i
think i think we should we should be
socialists and then everyone is chanting
we should be socialists over and over
again
so it was effective it was brilliant it
was evil very evil
amazing psychological tests it's really
famous and i can't think of the name of
it right now but i was watching it last
night
um where they they show they put
a person in a room with a bunch of
actors and
they have a poster with different
different lengths of lines
and they'll be like which two lines are
the same and the actors all
conformally like they all say the wrong
one
and then they watch and like that the
person who's not an actor the first time
will be like it's b
b and a are the same and then after a
few rounds
he'll start going along with what
everybody else said and
it's been repeated like hundreds of
times people are and it's
always dumb they always conform to what
you see monkey do well we talked about
this there was a test there was a viral
video
where they did this where they had a
doctor's office
and then it's a bunch of actors sitting
down and the non-actor the
the mark walks in sits down then you
hear a beep
and then all the actors stand up for
about five seconds and then sit back
down
so eventually the the mark that actor is
looking around like why is everyone
standing
then start standing up and sitting down
with them not knowing why just
everybody's doing it might as well do it
eventually this one guy was like what
what are you guys doing and he's like
you just was
supposed what we're supposed to do it's
like okay so here's the best part
one by one they removed the actors and
started putting in non-actors until
everyone who was there had no idea why
they were mindlessly standing up and
sitting down when the beeps happened
but they just do and when the guy was
like what are you doing like i don't
know everyone's just doing it
it's like that's not a good reason to do
anything yeah i mean they did that study
with animals and there's also the other
one where they had
uh a patient execute someone thinking
that it was the right thing to do
because they had someone in authority
tell him to do it and they were present
well
they were electrocuting someone with
higher and higher execute
potato potato well essentially
essentially
at the end of the study the guy died
right
he faked his death but to the point
where the guy was being told what to do
he just
kept clicking the button and then
executed the guy so i think it's because
it's more important for us to adapt than
to be right
uh sociologically historically for us to
survive it was more important
even if we were doing what we know is
wrong if it's the thing that
fits the situation we would do it and
those would be the people that would
survive so it's like in our dna
to say that the wrong thing is right if
everyone else is doing it
social it's like tribalism that's what
fractional reserve ban i think that's
when people see this fiat
fake money printing they can't
understand that dude well let's explain
it a little bit in
1970 nixon took us off the gold standard
and instituted fiat currency so that the
federal reserve could print as much
money
didn't they seize gold they did yeah i
remember that yeah
they said like you got it you gotta give
your gold up and shot taking it
from what i know about fractional
reserve banking is that if a bank
a central bank loans a hundred dollars
to a bank
uh then the bank can take ninety percent
of that money and loan it out
and then the person that receives that
ninety dollars
gets to loan out ninety percent of that
so they can loan out eighty one dollars
of that
so you've created from that initial
hundred dollars a hundred and seventy
one dollars
so the money supplies expanded yeah the
issue is that
if you have like the easiest way to
explain the the issue
what happens is so you've created fake
money and then you request interest back
on the fake money
so it's this giant pyramid scheme right
and eventually the the the uh the
interest outweighs
the the money supply and then pops but
the easiest way to explain this because
people are gonna be like i have no idea
what that means is
if you have a rare painting it's worth a
bunch of money
if all of a sudden there's complete and
exact replicas like
a hundred like let's say you got you got
a rare luke rudkowski original pressing
and it's worth just a mere
one thousand dollars because luke's not
you know necessarily a famous painter
but it's
it's a unique painting made by him or a
thousand bucks all of a sudden one day
someone opens a vault and there's a
thousand of them
well now it's not valuable anymore
because there's just tons of them who
wants them
everybody who wants one gets one and
then nobody's trading them anymore so
when they just keep mass printing money
with no st
with no standard with no backing then
the value is just the confidence of
individuals
in that system and what happens is the
more they print the more
your values do it's inflation well the
scary thing is
right now if if enough people go to the
bank to try to get their money back they
won't be able to
a lot of people think that if they put
their money in the bank it's there and
it's kept safe for them
it's not but that's true with or without
fractional reserve yes
so but that exer that makes the problem
a little bit worse yeah
runs on the banks or problems yeah the
fact that they can loan out money that
they don't have is is
is crazy that you could buy they don't
create the money
and then loan out 90 of it
and but still keep your 100. listen
listen so ponzi scored
ponzi schemes work really great so long
as no one dares
get you know screw with your system to
put it mildly
so the united states the petro dollar
the fractional reserve system
it's brilliant we just got to keep
printing the money we'll keep expanding
and we'll keep growing and keep spending
and
and everything's great unless you know
someone like
gaddafi comes along and wants to trade
and what is it what do you want to do
and then you get a saddam hussein who
says maybe we should entertain the euro
and then well then you have no choice
but to uh can we drone this guy
you know can we join this guy and then
what hillary clinton say we came we saw
he died
and that's i'm not saying that's exactly
why you know the official
reasons as to why we you know drop bomb
drop bombs on countries
is because i guess they're bad people
you know they hate our freedom the
reason i'm railing on the fed is because
i think if we're going to start a new
political party it would be to repeal
the federal reserve act like ron paul
was the closest thing we had
to a new political party but i don't i
don't think that would work at this
point
oh gosh this is what our laps what other
you what other
unifying message do you think we can
nobody knows about the federal reserve
or what fractional reserve banking isn't
realistic exactly
like 50 000 people and no one's gonna
care because it doesn't impact their
immediate lives
if you if you went on the gold standard
right now a dollar would be
worth nothing like a gold flake no going
back to the gold standard doesn't make
sense
i think that's why you got it crypto
maybe bitcoin i don't know because you
can't print infinite amounts of it
there's a finite amount of it in the
in the supply thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you